[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in salehs wels
heute gibt es einen opec torte murat hat
nämlich was mitgebracht und zwar die
toffifee coconut limited edition
es bringt keine kooperation mit stock
morath läuft noch gerne mal durch dieses
wochen mit punkt und nimmt dann gern
neue süßigkeit mit deswegen hat er sich
auch eine torte gewünscht ich habe mir
jetzt gedacht weil wir sommer haben und
immer noch so bisserl mail knappheit
herrscht gibt es ein objekt orte denn
dafür braucht ihr kein mehl dafür nehmen
wir einfach kekse und ich habe überlegt
dass ich unten so einem keks boden mache
der schönen cara malick ist dann
obendrauf eine schöne seine schicht und
da packe ich dann diese coconut office
mit rein und obendrauf eine schöne deko
aber ich bin sozusagen ich musste jetzt
erst mal ausprobieren damit sie was
sagen kann wie die schmecken und
wird dort das so lohnt wenn nicht könnte
ja auch einfach ganz normale tür gewesen
wenn jetzt nicht so der cocos mensch
sein es ist nicht lustig wenn man hier
so drauf drückt
das geht normalerweise wasser bekommt
die sache und stücke live hacking und
claire sie sehen schon mal anders aus
als die anderen denn ihnen ist eine
weiße krämer co
pokemon probieren
aufgefangen
folge leckere coco stream füllung
drumrum karamell und
obendrauf die schokolade und das passt
echt gut fast richtig gut zusammen jetzt
geht auch das rathaus und kokos curry
dieser kleiner ich dann für die creme
ihnen rein
und dann eine schöne dicke obendrauf mit
tupfen und dann mit den top-teams und
vielleicht
karamellisiertem kokosnuss dazu mache
ich das ich fange jetzt aber erstmal mit
dem boden an
und zeigt euch dafür die zutaten dafür
brauchte nämlich nur drei
dafür nämlich 150 gramm butter 150 gramm
source it girl peaches und 180 gramm
butterkekse ich gebe jetzt zuerst mal
die butter in einem topf da kann ich die
butter nämlich schon schmelzen und die
soundkarte features ist ja so kleine
karamellbonbons die sehr lecker sind und
ich empfehle euch auch nett weil sie
einfach sehr süchtig machen ja also wenn
wir da einmal damit anfängt und außer
beim zutaten abwiegen und so da landet
schon mal die hand gern in der dose und
dann ist man halt mehr als man wollte so
morgens im joghurt aufs müsli genauso
deswegen am besten gar nicht erst
probieren ich erzähle butter die wird
geschmolzen
einfach beim mittel hoher hitze ihr
dürft ihr auch nie zu hoch erhitzen weil
dann spritzt die ganze butter raus und
die soll eigentlich nur warm werden wie
gesagt die fans kommen da gleich rein da
gibt es auch noch die sorte cookie dough
dies auch sehr gut
und die kekse kann ich dann schon mal zu
lange zerkleinern einfach in den mixer
oder mit einem austausch darüber rollen
und schön pulverisieren
vollgepackt mit tolle sachen die das
leben schöner machen hinein ins weekend
wartet kurz ich würde es nämlich keine
größere schäden gibt keine schüssel
dreckig machen
deswegen warte ich bis die butter
geschmolzen ist und dann kann ich die
vorschuss schnellsten und dann die kekse
reingeben und die zweite prozent kekse
nämlich schwarzer kleidung immer schönes
geschirr sparen beim kochen und backen
man danach nicht so viel ab was
muss ja auch sagen dass ich so für euch
für die videos immer alles in so kleinen
schälchen abwege und es ist auch gerade
für back anfänger immer ganz gut weil
man dann eben auch keine zutat vergisst
und sich alles schon herrichtet alles
griffbereit hat wenn ich natürlich als
privat ohne kamera koche und backe dann
fühle ich nicht alles immer in einzel
schüsseln ich mache dann auch oft so
eine große schüssel für das trockene und
eine große schüssel für die flüssigen
zutaten so wie ich es halt für das
rezept braucht und guckt immer so wenig
geschirr wie möglich zu verursachen
dann ist noch schneller fertig
ich sehe jetzt hier ganz gut die
falsches schmelzen aber sie verbinden
sich nicht mit der butter ist einfach
eine fertige machte und das hier ist
eine zuckrige masse aber das macht gar
nichts denn jetzt kommen hier einfach
die kekse rein und dann kann alles
vermengt werden und dann vermischt sich
es auch ganz gut
lecker lecker lecker
jetzt nehmt ihr euch hier einen
tortenring den habe ich auf 22 cm
eingestellt hier noch eine back folie
darunter
unseren torten retter dann kommt die
masse rein und wird schon flach gedrückt
und dann kann der boden erstmal im
kühlschrank und ich kann mich um die
sahne creme kümmern
schlafstörungen
nee ich noch so
für die creme verwende ich 125 gramm
toffifee 500 gramm mascarpone 50 gramm
butter zucker vanille extrakt 400 gramm
sahne und etwas sonderbar zum steif
schlagen
dann nehmen wir jetzt erstmal betroffen
wäre hier raus die toffifee
2010/2011 ich hätte so viel
süßigkeiten nimmt jetzt raus und könnte
selbst beim hacken
sehr schön dann kommt es kurz zur seite
und ihr könnt die mascarpone verrühren
mit puderzucker und wandel exakt
hier könnt ihr jetzt hier die sonne
langsam zu gießen und die creme mit
seiner partei schlagen
von der steif geschlagene creme nimmt
jetzt am besten so ungefähr 200 gramm
raus die brauche ich nämlich später für
die sahne tupfer und die stellt jetzt
einfach beiseite und packt sie eben in
den kühlschrank
und in die restliche creme kommen jetzt
die toffees mit rein
jetzt nimmt er die toffifee süßigkeiten
und könnte jetzt hier unterheben und ich
hoffe ich habe genug davon rein wird
neben war einfach noch bissl mehr
drucker anna wollt ihr probieren
wow
als ich hier noch sorgen pernod falsches
rein
jetzt probiert mal anders möchte den
löffel zu schmeißen oder das holz
engagiert in kürze
auch wieder da
pro firma
mehr gucken
ein bisschen geht schon noch gern
das machen wir die 200 haben soll und
das sage ich als nicht gerade grossartig
akkus liefen
dann kommt jetzt hier die creme direkt
auf den tortenboden und wird schön glatt
verstrichen
jetzt ist die creme schön glatt die
torte kommt in den kühlschrank für etwa
zwei stunden die andere creme habe ich
ja auch schon im kühlschrank und dann
wird danach die torte fertig dekoriert
ich überlege mir jetzt noch ob da noch
seine
karamellsoße ich muss mal gucken denn
die ist ja schon sich
mit otto schenk dekorierte jetzt erst
mal auf einer schönen tortenplatte
ist immer einfacher das forderte co zu
machen
dann den ring entfernen
und klebte aber ordentlich
ich glaube das ist
das liegt laut streichen
und da nehme ich einen torten einteiler
und maki mir zwölf stücke
dann die sahne creme die ich
zurückgelegt habe da kommen jetzt
einfach schöne flugverlauf
dann kommt da jetzt die trophy
süßigkeiten drauf und weil sie akkus
tokio sind habe ich jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen kokosraspeln in der pfanne
gerüstet so leicht karamell farben und
schön abkühlen lassen und ich denke ja
so viel für sie drauf dann streue ich
noch die kokosraspeln drauf und dann
noch hier diese crystals das sind ja so
kekse die ummantelt sind mit kuvertüre
einmal mit karamell und mit peter kolba
töre und ich habe noch vier tore
vielleicht mache ich noch mal gucken wie
geht s gleich wird
jetzt die torte fertig und kann
verkostet werden gitta magst du
probieren ja klar
[Applaus]
ist wie auch in
demut sprachfähigkeit mal so ein monster
torten
gibt es nicht irgendwo in der
sesamstraße das so nicht so montiert ist
so biss und dort die augen hat ich
glaube
ich glaube auch ein frosch oder soja
oder später kalt deswegen gegen der
boden ganz so schwer tue ich hab das
merken aber ich hoffe sie ist sehr
lecker
richtig
muss die neue
sind schon gut
ja so richtig
wissen
weniger
ich glaube
das nicht ganz so süß mag lieber ein
bisschen weglassen aber so an
ich mag vor allem den boden
und die toffees die schmelzen
man sieht sein das ist
läuft aber sieht richtig gut aus
also falls ihr die tochter über nacht im
kühlschrank lagert abgedeckt wird erst
am nächsten tag drauf
damit müssen
da lässt sich ja eigentlich im rat
probieren was müssen den ersten karamell
fällen und toll wie viel fern aber das
kann ich jetzt leider machen er kann
direkt gleich die torte probieren und
falls ihr diesen objekten nach machen
wollt dann schaut gern auf cds - blog.de
vorbei oder in meiner app da findet die
autos rezept und schreibt mir gern auch
mal welche dann objekt rotten bisher
euer favorit war also möglich ist er so
billig oder fruchtig oder zitrone oder
schokoladig schreibt camerons titanic in
summe
es gibt noch ein op klemme
aber der kommt erst noch online nationen
renten gelb also max kern natürlich
super bis zum nächsten mal
dass die zeit immer schnell gerne keks